it's a reflection about the line parallel to K a0 which we'll call L1 just to give it a
name to see why it's a reflection it helps to draw a picture here we have our two vectors K
a0 and K A1 which are orthogonal unit vectors and we can think about the screen as consisting of all of the real
linear combinations of these two vectors so the circle represents all of the unit vectors for which the coefficients of
these two vectors are real numbers here's the line L1 which is parallel to K a0 and if we consider some
arbitrary Vector s on this circle then the effect of applying ZF is to reflect about this line as is Illustrated on the
screen simply because we do nothing to k a z and we put a minus sign in front of K
A1 in the special case that s is k a zero for instance nothing happens when we perform this reflection and when s is
K A1 the reflection takes us all the way to negative K A1 and that's consistent with the action of ZF so ZF is a
reflection that can be visualized as we have here the second part of G which is z or
sandwich between two layers of hatar gates can be expressed as 2 * K Bru minus the identity Matrix as we've
already scene and again this is a reflection this time about the line L2 parallel to k u rather than K
a0 we can visualize this operation in a similar way to ZF here's the vector k
hypothetically so this is the line L2 parallel to K and once again the action on an arbitrary Vector S is to reflect
it about the line which is L2 in this case
and finally as I mentioned before whenever we compose two Reflections we obtain a rotation and specifically it's
a rotation by twice the angle between the lines of reflection so let's draw a similar
picture to what we had before here are the lines of reflection which have the angle Theta between
them and if we take some arbitrary Vector s reflected around the first line L1 and
then reflected about the second line L2 then the net effect will be to rotate the vector s by an angle of twice Theta
and this is something that's true in general and you can try it out on some additional examples of your own to see that this is indeed the way it
works anyway hopefully this helps you to get some intuition as to why the grover operation has the effect of rotating
vectors next we'll turn to the issue of choosing the the number of iterations T in Grover's
algorithm let's start by thinking about how the analysis we've seen so far which reveals what the grover operation does
when we apply it repeatedly to the uniform superposition relates to the task that we're hoping to solve which is to find a solution to our search problem
or in other words any string contained in the set A1 in short we're basically going to set
a Target and then figure out how many times to apply the grover operation to get close to that
Target first let's imagine that we have any state that's a linear combination of our two vectors K a0 and K
A1 if we perform a standard basis measurement on this state we're going to get an outcome in the set A1 which is
the set of solutions to our search problem with probability equal to the absolute value squar of whatever coefficient we have for K A1 and for the
vector that's shown on the screen that coefficient is beta this is is intuitive if we were to measure the state K a0
we'd get a random nons solution and if we measured K A1 we'd get a random solution so if we measure this state
right here we'll get a random non-solution with probability absolute value of Alpha squ and a random solution
with probability absolute value of beta squ but we can also just take a moment to work it out here's the State written
out so that we can see what the entries of this Vector are for standard bis States so if we measure these are the
probabilities to obtain each possible outcome and to get the probability to obtain a solution we sum the
probabilities for all of the possible solutions which gives us the absolute value of beta squar as
expected now we've already analyzed what happens when we run Grover's algorithm for T iterations we get the state that's
shown here on the screen so because the coefficient of K A1 is the S
of 2T + 1 * Theta where once again here is this very important angle Theta we
will see a solution with probability sin^2 of 2T +1 *
Theta we'd like to make that probability large ideally as close to one as we can so as we're rotating the state
vector by iterating G we'll think about K A1 as the target state and we'll try
to pick T so that we land close to this state and as we're doing this it's good to keep in mind that we'd also like to
minimize T because that's the number of queries we need to make so if we want to make this
probability close to one and minimize T it Mak sense to try to make the angle of our state Vector close to Pi / 2 because
that's the smallest angle that makes the square of the sign large so it's basically our first opportunity to make the probability large as we're
rotating the state Vector now we can't necessarily hit this angle pi over 2 exactly because T has to
be an integer but if we think about it approximately and solve for t as if it were inequality then we see that ideally
choosing T to be pi over 4 * Theta minus 12 makes
sense but of course T must be a non- negative integer so what we'll do is to
take the closest integer to what we're imagining is this ideal value which is the floor of pi divided 4 *
Theta taking the floor by the way just means that we throw away any fractional part so in other words it's the largest
integer that's less than or equal to whatever it is that we're taking the floor of according to this expression if the
ideal value happens to be halfway between integers we'll round up but that won't actually matter at all for for the
sake of this lesson so going forward we're going to be focusing on this particular choice of
T but there is one other important consideration that we need to make which is that this specification of T depends
on how many solutions there are because the angle Theta depends on the number of
solutions Hereafter I'm going to use the letter s to refer to the number of solutions or in other words the size of
the set a one just for the sake of convenience anyway the point is that our
expression for T the value that we're hypothesizing should be good depends on Theta and Theta depends on S which is